[Music]
[Music]
welcome to wisdom for life where we sit
through philosophy to find practical
advice that you can use in your everyday
life hi i'm dan hayes i'm joined by my
co-host dr greg sadler and today we're
talking about breaking and replacing new
year's resolutions so
you can participate in this in any way
if you've already made new year's
resolutions or already broke your new
year's resolutions or don't have any
this is all very useful because we're
going to talk about
why there's nothing really special about
new year's itself and
how it might be better to think of it
less in terms of resolutions and more in
terms of goals and we've got a lot of
cool stuff lined up but we should talk
first about this i mean what would you
call it it's a tradition it's a practice
it's something a lot of people do did
your family always do new year's
resolutions dan
no not really there was nothing like
s codified as something to do to to
present them
to each other it's yeah it's just it's
something that's in the the general
milieu of being
you know
in the united states i guess sea and
mines from other places as well yeah and
and among friends it was a very common
thing getting together at like new
year's parties to do two things one was
to make new year's resolutions and then
to make new year's predictions
and we'd write the predictions down and
put them in like an envelope or
something like that and then get them
out you know the next year and see if
any of them came true but it was
considered kind of important to make
some sort of
new year's resolution i don't know maybe
my family was a little bit more
moralistic than yours was sir you know
but there's something of that and and i
think you're right it's become a a
general feature of american culture
and it's you know it's not something
radically new i mean people have been
celebrating new year's
since you know the well let's let's just
call it the dawn of civilization because
some of the oldest civilizations
around
did in fact have some sort of new year's
celebrations and they did sometimes have
resolutions so we see
babylonian
utranian that's still carried through
with now rose today
chinese new year is a big deal
the romans had their new year's
celebrations that were associated with
with giannis this uh two-headed god and
people would sometimes
take the opportunity to do a little bit
of thinking about their life and how
screwed up it is and
how they might want to get it back on
track and some of them would make um
commitments i i don't know that they
were called
resolutions
and the polling right now says that
about 40 to 50 percent of americans make
new year's resolutions so that's a lot
of people and i don't know what it's
like in in europe or in south america or
other places but i mean that's probably
enough that we could
hash this topic out quite a bit
and so
like personally
yeah i don't find they're like we've
defined at a moment
of an arbitrary position based on
tradition
uh of of creating some sort of
resolution based on the new year and
yeah you know at least within the
northern hemisphere of the world
i wouldn't really consider
you know the doldrums of winter to be
the best time to actually start
implementing big new changes in your
life
i well they could be though i mean
so it's the darkest time of the year i
mean it's not the solstice itself right
the solstice is a little bit earlier
but it's still pretty dark a lot of the
time
and it's that weird kind of
end of the year you know the holidays we
call it but a lot of it means we're just
kind of floating and and having
obligations that have to do with you
know
colleagues or family or stuff like that
for those of us who are academics you
know we're in the break in between
uh fall semester and spring semester or
perhaps january term that might be
starting up for some
and so you know it could be a good time
to
like take some time and reflect i mean
is it the best time to make
big decisions just because it's the
turning over of a new year maybe not
yeah you're probably right i don't know
about this making the decisions
themselves but starting to implement
them and i would just and i guess i will
maybe so we've got
this right we've got reflection we've
got making the decision we've got
implementing the decision and maybe it's
not fortuitous for all three of them
right right and especially if we're
talking about
some sort of uh athletic
okay um thing and where it's the best
and easiest to do this outside but if
it's right
10 degrees outside like it is currently
on i don't really don't want to start a
running routine
starting at 10 degrees so there are
places where these become
easier to implement um and so for those
types of things i'd actually say
the implementation might be better or
started at if you're going to choose an
arbitrary point yeah you know um the
equinox and or easter
yeah i think especially here in
wisconsin i think you're right i mean if
you're living in california i guess you
could do whatever you want whatever you
want basically right um and some places
it might be too hot during the
what they have of spring and summer and
fall to do much outdoor stuff
but i mean you could do ice skating
right you could pick up ice skating and
we can't do cross-country skiing because
unfortunately we don't get as much snow
anymore as we used to um but you know
you could do other things i will say
this though we know that
lots and lots and lots of people
will purchase gym memberships or renew
gym memberships and
january is the month where gyms make
their most money because people are
signing up for things and
what we know is that most of these
people are not going to follow through
for more than a few weeks
and so and that's built into the the
business model of most of these gym
memberships especially the ones that are
cheap so if you look at your your
uh 10 or 15 a month gym membership
places they expect only you know
20 of the people that actually have
memberships to actually use it this is a
little bit off topic but i
suspect and you tell me what you think
about this
that if you're only paying 10 or 15 a
month it's a lot easier to like keep it
and and not cancel it because you're not
paying 100 bucks a month right so if
you're paying 100 bucks a month and it
gets to be march and you're like i
haven't gone to the gym more than you
know three times
then that's an expense to cut but if
it's just you know the cost of netflix
basically
or some other streaming service uh who
you know who notices right it's just a
couple couple coffees or uh it's not
even you know
it's it's a portion of a tank of gas it
doesn't uh
doesn't add up so maybe people just
keep the meter running for
months and months and years and years
yeah you know it's it's easy to say oh
yeah it's how can i go to the gym next
month i've always have access to it yeah
but not actually do it but yeah if
you're going to high-end place 100 150
200 a month like i need to get my
money's worth or that needs to go yeah
that's a good good way of putting it i
have access to it whenever i want right
and you can just kind of keep it in the
back of your mind as well i could be
going to the gym i'll do it tomorrow
um but another thing is
that
uh
basically we have these new year's
resolutions because it is a
it's probably a good thing to try to
reflect and maybe make changes on our
lives um yeah and having a you know an
annual tradition to do that that's a
perfectly fine thing but
the best time
to
make change is when you realize that
there's something wrong in your life and
so you know it is nice to have a a
reminder um but one shouldn't wait until
new year's to start changing something
in their life they see that there's
something wrong yeah i mean you could
have something like a deferred
resolution right a resolution to
do a resolution later on or you're like
listen
well like you were saying you know um
i'm i'm not going to start running
in january in milwaukee i mean there's
ice all over the place and it's cold and
like the wind today was super blustery i
wouldn't want to be out there running
but come you know
end of march april
that that might not be so bad i think
you know i used to run track when i was
in high school
and i kind of think
that we started running
um
like end of january early february but i
also remembered it really sucked
you know
i bet if you're doing a high school and
you're a freshman and that's your first
experience of like running
how many people you know drop out of
track and field that first week of like
it's really bad and bliss uh blustery
yeah good question um or you know and
and if you're coming in and joining
cross country it's hot right you're
you're beginning it uh when it's still
summer and you gotta run all these miles
and you know if you if you are a
freshman you're going to be lagging
behind
all these upper-class people who uh are
much better runners than you and
yeah yeah so okay what are some of the
the resolutions that people tend to make
yeah so there's this this site called
ghostskills.com and i don't know that
this is the definitive list i think it's
a plausible list of the most common
resolutions
so here's here's what they are
exercise more we already talked about
that
lose weight
get organized
learn a new skill or hobby live life to
the fullest
save more money or spend less money quit
smoking spend time more time with family
and friends
travel more and read more now i mean i'm
kind of curious what do you make of that
particular list it's probably accurate
about what people do pledge but what do
you notice about all of these
not not all but most of these
resolutions
they're kind of wishy-washy there's no
actual
demonstrable thing
that you can say i've either made it or
not okay
i mean lose weight you can say well if
you ended the year
at the same weight you haven't lost
weight
right but like oh i lost a pound well
like hooray
like
sure good good on you but like that's
also within like the just the natural
fluctuations of your weight is going to
have
might be it might be because the scale's
slightly tougher
right
um but yeah i see it you know most of
these are
uh it's just like get organized how do
you define what is organized like what
is your criteria for um what does a
living life to the fullest actually
means that one seems to be the vaguest
one right yeah
what do you think though about the learn
a new skill or hobby um i mean it's not
specifying what the
skill is you don't really learn a hobby
i think
you acquire a hobby but
um yeah there are skills that are
entailed within the hobby yeah
like stamp collecting you got to figure
out how to put it into your little book
and
you know
if you're doing rabbit grooming you got
to learn how to use a comb or something
or you know we could probably come up
with all sorts of skillness
right
oh sure
rabbit grooming sorry you threw me off
there you know
i was just thinking when i was a kid
growing up out in the sticks 4h was
super big and my mom wanted me to be
involved in in 4h
and some of the
other people who were involved in 4-h in
my neighborhood
they were i don't know how 4-h is
organized because it's been so long
since i looked at it but there's
something like you you specialize in
different areas
and these people had rabbits i thought
well rabbits are pretty cool you know
maybe i could get into this and then i
found out all the work that was involved
in rabbits and i quickly decided nah
this this is not for me
but i mean there are people who you know
probably make that their their hobby
right and there would be a whole bunch
of skills involved like you're saying
but none of them are specified in the
actual resolution if i if i say well i'm
going to become
really good with guinea pigs or
i don't know what else you could you
could pick
what do you think though about the
um read more
that's quantifiable right
yeah
but like
it's still
not like
i would if i was going to set some sort
of resolution
on it for a quantifiable one i'd see
like okay i would i would like to read
down 10 books this year okay that's kind
of a low low goal but that is a goal
that is
demonstratable um but you know as we'll
get into later i don't actually think
those types of goals are actually good
so why not i mean let's give a little
preview okay so uh basically
uh one um that you're once you've hit
that goal then you no longer have any
motivation to continue doing that oh so
hey maybe maybe you go on a tear and you
get to your ten go uh books by march
yeah um
i did it hooray um
did you
as i'll show
later like one of the better ways to do
this is to like define
like oh i might want to read an hour
every night or we're in an
as a you know grade school or high
schooler in one of those summer
library reading programs
yeah
did not do well in those why not
i don't
know
um
like the pizza wasn't a good motivation
it's usually the thing that you got
uh because i i guess looking back there
was no structure to how i was going to
achieve those goals yeah
it was just a goal it kind of like
floated out there
um
i kind of think that exactly what you
were talking about just a couple minutes
ago where somebody's like well i got to
read 10 books all right so i'll read
these 10 books now i'm done i don't have
to read anything more
there's there's something that's missing
there
about
why reading is valuable
i mean i never had any problem with it
because i was always reading books
anyway so i'd be like well i'll just
count the books i'm already reading
and get the prizes or whatever it is
that they're they're offering get my mom
off my back or you know whatever
whatever the impetus was but it was
totally extrinsic to what my activity
already was it would be sort of like you
know in my case
um saying well you gotta you know you
you need to drink water each day and i'd
be like well i already drink water each
day so that's covered i'm i'm good with
that you know
so um
as we'll get into it later but like you
know what are some of the um
the patterns are the resolutions that
you got had in the past
well i've made some good ones and some
bad ones and i think we could probably
all say that right
yeah right the best new year's
resolution that i ever made
was one that got me out of a toxic
relationship um
and i it was back in graduate school i
was dating this woman and she was just
you know all sorts of bad news uh in all
sorts of other ways and then actually
you know like
sharing stories with others who had gone
out with her i found that this was like
a pattern but um
i broke up with her at new year's
i called her i remember i said i'm
breaking up with you and that's my new
year's resolution and i'm going to stick
to it
and i did
and um you know that was so that's a
good one right but that's
basically you just got to not date that
person anymore so it's not that
difficult of a resolution
i've made all sorts of other ones that i
haven't been able to follow through on
like
you know i learned a bit of mandarin
when i was in college and i've always
said well i'm this will be the year i
buckle down and finally you know study
and learn more than 250 characters never
happens um i've started out okay with
that but it's never really gotten
through um i've said i would drop 50
pounds and get in shape that's a bit
ambitious for somebody like me i think
i actually have lost 30 pounds this year
but i didn't do it by making a new
year's resolution i did it by getting
back to the gym and doing weight circuit
training which turned out to be pretty
pretty useful and i was very surprised
when i got on the scale
um what else um
i've said i wouldn't argue with my wife
um
that you know i mean going a year
without that i mean think about
epictetus discourses where he's talking
about anger and he's like you know if
you make it one day without losing your
temper then
mark it down if you go three days now
you're actually now you're as we say
you're cooking with gas right if you
make 30 days
then go in and offer a sacrifice to the
gods because you've accomplished
something really major i i don't go a
week without arguing with anybody who's
close to me i think you know so so that
was
you know some of these resolutions have
to not just be actionable and specified
they actually have to be things that you
could plausibly do
not just aspirational now what about you
you you've made resolutions in the past
right
yeah like um
i took a kinesiology course in college
and that was one of the really the first
times that like i actually knew
some science behind
on both diet and exercise and how these
things work in a more robust a
systematized way
then so
uh one of the resolutions that i had
there was to
run a half marathon on
and so on
it is a lot of running because it's it
takes a long time to get your uh
statement stamina up to the point where
you can actually do you know the was it
13 13 0.1 miles yeah oh man so um i've
never run that that that far in my life
the longest i ever ran was 10 miles and
that was once
yeah
um but i found a really a good program
and and set up the entire thing it's
like you know you've got six days a week
that you run and then the seventh day
you do something else
that's active but it's not running so
like riding your bike or something um
and so you you go between like short
runs and longer runs so you start out
like doing like two miles um and then
you do like a four mile run and it keeps
on going up until you're like average
run your slo or short run is like five
miles and then you're just starting to
do like eight nine ten eleven run miles
um i was i'm really good on that i
followed that through to the t
partly because i had created a really
achievable goal and uh
every once in a while i might not be
able to make it one day and i just kind
of like dropped it like that's okay
there's the rest of the thing i just
keep on going um try to hit my metrics
um until i hurt my foot one day when i
was doing a
12 mile run so i got like at least 11
miles up into it and i hurt my foot and
i started taking up more biking but i
counted that as a win
because
um i had gotten to the point where i
could run for fun that i got that that
point of like getting the runners high
and be able to like just kind of like go
into the woods and running on trails and
just enjoying that experience yeah and i
think that was more important in the end
like that i i was able to
um
see really continual improvement um over
a long period of time that does strike
me as as something really important and
and maybe we'll come back to that as an
example when we're looking at um
how to rework
resolutions because it would have been
really easy to say i'm going to run
every day why because i want to do this
half marathon but instead you set up the
half marathon is the thing that you're
shooting for
and then you've got some flexibility in
the
means that you choose to attain it and
then you've you've created sort of a
secondary
we'll call it a secondary goal although
you could actually think of it as a like
another resolution i've got this program
i'm gonna stick to this program and then
after uh things didn't work out you were
still able to
see how there was benefit there and i
think a lot of people make resolutions
this is jumping ahead a bit again
if if they if things don't work out with
their resolution they feel really bad
right because they've invested so much
in things being this particular way you
know so like if you had insisted oh it's
got to be a half marathon
rather than it's got to be
long-term consistent exercise i think
you would have probably felt bad right
right
um but like ao as we i think we'll talk
about later it's like you gotta
know that there are certain things that
are outside of your control um and you
know i hurt myself it made it so that i
was uh unable to run for
you know at least a month of
and and so that really sets you back and
then by that time i was able to
i took up biking a lot more and i just
like well that's now my new big cardio
thing and i would go on like you know 20
mile rides yeah
which is which is also quite nice i mean
one of the things that's nice about
running or walking is getting out in
nature and seeing things you know
and like you said the the whole moving
your body aspect and you can do that
just as well on a bike
i suppose as any anything else right
yeah i think one of the other things
that was um
motivating me at that point in time was
there's a quote from socrates about like
oh uh something along the lines of it's
it is a travesty if a
man does not know the full extent of
what their body can do hmm
okay
uh
yeah it's interesting you know this is a
total digression but we we think about
these
ancient philosophers
and
we think of them as you know big brains
walking around and
what we could see most of the time is
their
their thoughts that are written down in
dialogue form or treaties form or letter
form or stuff like that
and we forget that almost all of them
engaged in physical
discipline and exercise
some of the philosophy schools were
actually at gymnasiums you know the kuno
sarges uh where the cynics went was a
gymnasium um
and
all of them
they didn't think that the body was the
most important thing obviously they you
know the life of the mind i think they
thought the mind was most important but
they did think that you don't want your
body to be an impediment to
mental activity you want it healthy you
want it strong you want it able to get
around and do the things that it needs
to do and some of them as they were
older like socrates or like seneca
um they had you know
a decent life because they had attended
to their
their bodies needs
yeah so i just pulled up the quote
really quick no man has the right to be
an amateur in the matter of physical
training it is a shame for a man to grow
old without seeing the beauty and
strength which his body is capable
that's that's pretty good
yeah
you know actually i'll mention another
thing that i i was saying jokingly with
a few uh friends earlier you know john
madden died recently the great um uh nfl
commentator and and you know athlete and
all that but you know he
once he got out he didn't really look
that athletic um once he started eating
and
less exercise and the guy made it to 85
years old you know you look at john
manning you're like how did this guy
make it to 85 and then i think about
that myself i'm i'm 51
this
this last year and i say well
you know i'm past the halfway point but
if madden can make it to 85 i bet if i
exercise and you know eat the right
stuff provided i don't get hit by the
boss or you know die of some disease or
something like that i'll i'll get to 85
and that gives me something to look
forward to because then i think and
maybe this can tie back into resolutions
i think oh you know the end is not that
close i've still got plenty of time to
work on the stuff that i want to work on
yes i mean you're on the other side of
that you know in your in your 30s
are you starting to like think in terms
of
what you know what you want to do
in the decades to come
how you know what condition you want to
be in or you know these are things that
go beyond like a one-year resolution
right oh yeah these are like it's a kind
of like a lifetime habit type thing and
i i've looked at
the studies about uh what makes your
life not only long but also enjoyable
into your old age and definitely one of
them is one of the things you do which
is uh strength training yeah
having a regular strength training
regimen both
maintains the
uh
strength of
not only your uh
muscles but also your bones and right
those are one of the main things that
will allow you to be
maintain your mobility
along into your life and once you lose
your mobility you're
it's it's a pretty it becomes much more
difficult too
yeah
well let's go um yeah let's come back to
a resolution so
what is it that resolutions reveal to us
when we look at
those that people make or our own i
think there's a lot of stuff you know we
we get to see you know if somebody's
making a resolution presumably it's
about something that they consider to be
important or valuable so
you know when we see that well you know
look at this list right you know we have
all these physical things we should read
more spend more time with
family those sound like pretty good
things
lose weight might be a good thing or not
a good thing depending on you know what
kind of
um
what kind of weight you're carrying get
organized uh you know it's nice to be
organized but
for what what what's the point of of the
organization i mean somebody could be
organized just for the sake of being
organized or they could like
have bought into the uh marie condo
thing and be all about you know does
this spark joy no let's get rid of it
you know i only have 50 books you can
buy into programs like that and and
that can be what a person values more
than anything else right
yeah this uh
whole prioritization and also the fact
that we only have you know
everyone's only got 24 hours a day right
right yeah and
we only can focus on so many things
within that a lot amount of time
and
oh what is that guy the uh the oracle
omaha um
oh is that warren buffett
yeah so um
there's a little
missive that he put out once which was
uh okay take the 10 most important
things in your life
and prioritize them
put them all in a list okay
and once you've done that
chop off the bottom seven because you
only have time
for three wow to do only if you actually
want to do them well
to not be stretched too thin
you have three goals
and
that was really kind of like an
interesting oh
what what can i actually succeed at well
yeah and what are the three things that
i'm going to prioritize in my life
yeah that would be tough for me i would
i mean now that you've already given
away the spoiler it'd be probably yeah
because there's a temptation to like
think about what sort of list i ought to
have you know
um
what kind of what kind of list
i desire to be the kind of person who
would generate you know
uh i actually i wanted to say something
about this
there's this notion of second order
desires that we've talked about before
in the past and
for those who are listening second order
desires are not desires for something
uh specifically like you know i desire
to have a ham sandwich or i desire to go
lay down and take a nap or you know i
desire to go and pet my cat or something
like that they're instead second order
desires are desires about desires so
their desires about what we
what what we would like to desire so i
can well the exercise thing is a great
example right there are some times when
um i make myself go to the gym
and i don't really want to go to the gym
and i kind of would like to be the the
sort of person who would want to go to
the gym because i know it's good for me
i know that my desires that i have are
kind of out of whack
um and you know it's a good thing to
have those second order desires because
those are how you talk about
prioritization that helps us to
to prioritize but there's also a danger
involved with it that i think comes up
quite a bit with resolutions which is
of being much more aspirational than
realistic
you know i can say
i would like to be the kind of person
who and then the the new year's
resolution
is a way for me to make myself think
that i'm on the path to being that kind
of person
right
um
so i guess uh who are we um
resolving these things for
to whom
yeah i mean that's something worth
considering as well
resolutions are kind of like promises or
vows or
maybe there's some other words that we
would use i you know i resolve it's what
we call a performative speech act right
uh
it's it's something that we're
making and now
um in the in the distant past people
made these to the gods you know
zeus is my witness i will do this or
this or this right um
i don't think we're doing that too much
today as a matter of fact
new year's resolutions
i don't know any any people who are
um
religious believers today who view their
new year's resolutions as like a pact
with god or anything
maybe there are maybe my my range of
experience is just too narrow
i mean do you at
don't
all
so who are they too
are they
we could make them to others i guess
no we could say they're to us
potentially
um but okay so if they're
if they are to other people yeah why are
the other two other people let's go back
to that uh so
why um maybe because i feel like
if i do this thing then i will fit more
into
a socially acceptable
box yeah um and so i'm making these
resolutions
in
you know benefit of the community and
what i think that the community wants me
to be well that's interesting because
that's like
that's also aspirational but it's like
taking somebody else's ideas about the
person that you ought to be and trying
to live up to that
right right
i mean that's a good reason but that is
a place that one could resolve it to
yeah i mean i think it could be as
trivial as like everybody's gotten
together on new year's eve and everyone
else has made resolutions and you're
like well i don't want to be the odd guy
out so i better come up with some sort
of resolution on the spot
well i've resolved to not reso have any
resolutions yeah that's like when i was
a kid and they'd ask us what are you
giving up for lent and we'd say i'm
giving up giving things up right
yeah
you know you could also i mean you could
be in like a relationship with somebody
who's very big about
resolutions and all this sort of stuff
and they could pressure you you have to
have a resolution you know i want you to
be the kind of person who is continually
making progress and developing in their
life right and and maybe you're not so
into that but you're you're into the the
relationship
and so you take it on
that would be a possibility right that
would be to somebody else
yeah
um
i'd say another one is to our future
selves
if you consider
uh not ourselves at the moment but like
the
the person that we
you know aspired to be yeah
in that case it gets more complicated if
you think it through right because a
resolution is this promise about
what you're going to do from this point
onward into the future so it is indeed
your future self
in some way who has to carry out the
stupid resolution that you committed
yourself to as past self right or his
present self and yet you're also making
this as a resolution to that same future
self
so if they complain about it you could
say well this is for your own good
yeah
um
i didn't write this down but i just
popped in my head because of something
else i wrote down yeah um you've
resolved to a judge
doesn't have to be like a george in a
court of law but someone that is
actually going to judge you and
potentially hold you accountable okay
yeah for not doing that and so not only
is it just kind of like a wishy-washy
thing to
um your future self or just you know
something that you say but there are
actually you can build in consequences
yeah to not actually doing that and once
you've made that resolution
um
you can
be held accountable
yeah and that might actually be a way of
getting people to follow through on
those resolutions right
right i'll get to that later what if you
make a resolution in social media
you know and you're
being kind of braggy about it or not
being very public about it
have you made a commitment to like all
of your followers or friends or whatever
whatever else you got going on uh you
know different platforms have different
ways of calling it
i guess it depends on
how much you want to you worry about
being called a hypocrite
okay
that doesn't seem to bother many people
at all
[Laughter]
especially influencers you know
so um when i went on my big
uh like
habits kick a while ago one of the
things i did find
was there was a number of studies
talking about
saying your resolutions out loud if you
say
that i'm going to do this to someone
on it doesn't have to be at new year's
but like whenever you say i'm going to
do this yeah your brain kicks you out a
little bit of dopamine yeah yeah
and it vary the very same the pathways
that you usually get as a reward for
actually doing it and so
on especially if you go around and
telling all sorts of people that this is
the thing this is the grand good thing
that i'm going to do
um actually makes it more difficult for
you to actually do that thing yeah
because the brain is already getting the
reward that would have got if it had
actually done the thing in the first
place that is a big problem for writers
you you go to a writing group and
there's lots and lots of writing groups
and then you tell people about your
project
and then you're not going to get your
project done
and then you get to see them the next
week and they're like how's your project
going
well i didn't make as much progress as i
thought but i did have these really cool
ideas about the other stuff i'm gonna
put in the book or whatever it's gonna
be
i wanna know we should do that with the
radio show we should be like
you know we're coming up to our 50th
episode pretty soon we should be like
you know
we're practically at our 200th episode
and we've talked about all these other
things that we haven't actually talked
about you know we can just project them
right isn't there's uh a quote which is
writing is the
art of applying but two seats
oh
yeah
you know ursula k le guin actually has
this essay
and i don't remember which which uh
particular book of her non-fiction it's
in but you know she actually did a lot
of writing workshops and you know talks
to potential writers and she's stressed
she's like you're not going to want to
hear this but if you want to become a
writer
you must write and then write and then
write you can't
like talk to people at the coffee shop
about it you can't just do outlines you
have to sit down and actually write
stuff and she she goes on to say you
know most of the stuff that you write
for a while is going to be kind of crap
and you're you know you're going to get
attached to it because it's your baby
but it really is crap and you need to be
able to move on and write some more
stuff rather than sitting down to edit
the stuff that you've got that's not
particularly good just keep on plowing
through it's sort of like running right
i mean imagine if you were like i'm
training for a half marathon
and i did run this one mile stretch
i'm just going to go back over that one
mile stretch
right
oh
this
um
you you bring up this idea of like being
an artist and and creating something
that is art and most artists
have the eye of what is good art
before they have the ability to know to
actually make that good art okay and
that results in a lot of artists
whichever the medium to be disillusioned
either especially their early work
because they
see what they produce and they see it in
comparison to what they know is good and
they know that they are absolutely
lacking
um but you just got to keep on producing
because that's the only way you're going
to get to a point where
something that you're producing is
actually beneficial that reminds me of
somebody who um i teach in my classes
sometimes who's a very
undervalued philosophical stock and his
name is
lev or leo depending on how it's
translated chest off
and he was a russian jewish philosopher
who grew up in russia left after the
revolution made his way to paris and
then you know he had written a lot of
books before that and then he wrote
quite a few after that and in his book
all things are possible he talks about
how um a lot of ordinary people they
think oh creative activity must be so
awesome you know i look at the product
imagine what it must be like to produce
this thing it must be like fun all day
long and he says that is an incorrect
argument you know you're you're thinking
that because you're looking at it from
the wrong side you're not seeing
what it's like for the the poor bastard
artist who is like tearing his hair out
trying to go over the same lines unhappy
with them day after day after day all
you get to see is the finished product
the finished product looks great
and it's wonderful
but
you don't you didn't get to see any of
the back end where if we want to mix
some more metaphors where the sausage
was being made you know
right
all right i think we should really move
on to um some positive negatives about
resolutions
so what is positive about making new
year's resolutions i mean you've already
said
maybe it's you know there's nothing
special about new year's
what's
what's good about it
you got a time that is a tradition in
order to the very least reflect upon
your things your life and make some
decisions about potentially changing
that's always a good reflection is
um
in a productive sense is
usually a good thing for people yeah
as long as you're not like
obsessively ruminating yeah that's
exactly um
uh but you know we also
we're looking at like i would how do i
how would i like to see myself in the
future like what are the things that i
can prove about myself um you know
thinking about the relationships as well
as the the actions that you want to do
and you know definitely finding some
really concrete steps in order to try to
achieve those results
yeah that seems to be
very important if you don't make a
resolution you're you're not going to
come up with concrete steps right
concrete steps are more than the
resolution but
you got to do the one before the other
what's what's problematic then about
new year's resolutions
um setting yourself up for failure if
you if you don't do these well then you
can set yourself back on so this is
going to be the year that i you know do
something grand like i'm i'm going to
write the next american novel on the
great american novel or i'm going to you
know this year i'm going to be elected
president you know
[Laughter]
there are certain things that especially
this year when it's not an election year
are unattainable yeah yeah i mean you
could always modify and be like i'll be
president of the homeowners association
or president of the chess club or you
know something like that but yeah i mean
there's a lot of really unrealistic
resolutions people make um i mean the
one that you brought up before with like
running the half marathon
if if you were 80 years old maybe that
wouldn't be doable if you're in your 20s
okay that's that's pretty doable within
the scope of a year right
i'm gonna learn how to master the guitar
probably not doable in a year you know
you could probably make some good
progress a lot more than you would if
you never picked up a guitar but
there's there's yeah these this is going
to be the year
and i think some of the ones that that
we were talking about earlier like
getting organized this is going to be
the year i really get organized
i i think a lot of people um mess that
one up
yeah
what about what do you think about the
the time thing is new year's really the
best time for
coming up with
let's say you had to pick a time during
the year
mm-hmm
definitely wouldn't be new years because
i've got seasonal factory disorder and
okay that's a good consideration yeah
yeah no knowing your your rhythms and
how when you are most at a good place to
actually start implementing or even
thinking about these things it's
probably a good idea so how does sad
because i think maybe some of our
listeners you know here in wisconsin
it's a big problem right
because it's cold and it's dark but some
of our listeners might be in places
where it's not like that
how does that
how does that psychologically affect
your decision making does it does it
lead to
a general malaise you know
kind of like a low-level depressor
depression
um
it's it just you know it saps the energy
and
maybe you know reduces one's zest for
life you know i just sit here and if
you're uh watching the video of this um
here here's my nice uh bright satellite
um that comes on to help me you know
deal with that stuff but you know it's
you know dark here uh most of the day
you know in the northern hemisphere and
you got to do something about it i also
take some extra vitamin d um it still
doesn't stop it like my body's like you
should be in the sun more like there is
no sun yeah when i was in in college at
lakeland college
um there were a lot of people working in
the factories around there a lot of
students that i knew
and
some of them were working second or
third shift which meant that they were
sleeping during the day
and that meant that some of them didn't
see the sun at all for like weeks on end
and
man did that do a number on them you
know
yeah that reminds me of you know
i've definitely done that with work and
school here
both you know you wake up you go to
school it might be just barely light
yeah yeah and you go through your entire
day and it's all under you know um
artificial lights and then you get out
and it's already dark and it's like what
am i doing in this particular
environment yeah i mean it could be
worse we could be much further north
where they get like you know eventually
down to no
sunlight for for part of the uh
the year right
right
um
yeah up in the arctic circle anything
anything above the arctic circle will
have at least a day of you know 24 hour
no light
which is just
kind of mind-boggling yeah
well let's let's shift to talking about
something that i think will have come up
for quite a few of our listeners what if
you've already broken your new year's
resolution
right do you have to feel bad about that
or is this instead an opportunity and i
think there's a whole range of possible
attitudes and responses from the
catastrophic oh this is so awful
i can't believe one more year that i
didn't make my resolution and then you
just feel you know you like keep all
sorts of guilt and shame upon yourself
um some people will say oh well you know
better luck next year and then they just
abandon the resolution and i think
that's not actually a good stance either
i see no because like we have the
ability to automatically reset you know
any
uh obviously the easiest one is to think
about you know you put yourself on a
diet okay
and and you oh you
you cheat or something and you're like
well i've cheated once i can just cheat
the rest of the day you know you gorge
yourself yeah now you're you're setting
yourself much back much further back
than maybe
um the the the one piece of candy that
you may have eaten that you are not
supposed to you hey you have the ability
to reassert your resolution at any point
in time there's no like you don't have
to wait until the next day yeah yeah
it's like well i've got an infinite
amount of moments between now and then
i can choose any one of them to
get right back on the horse i think
people do that with uh i'm gonna quit
drinking i'm gonna quit smoking you know
they're like well
you know some people give up coffee
i'm already off so i may as well like
smoke the whole pack you know
and that doesn't make any logical sense
whatsoever yeah you're right i was like
i have a goal and i'm going to do
something to make it even worse
you know i another one that i think
people do is they make deals with
themselves
not only so like take the people who
they fall off the diet wagon and they're
like oh i'm gonna go like eat as much as
i can today and then they'll say well
but i'm going to be really strict with
myself going forward
i'm going to make up for this somehow
i don't think that really works i think
that's setting yourself up for more and
more failure
yeah in my opinion the consistency is
the key here um as much as you can keep
consistent with the thing you know you
don't try to fluctuate too much you
don't starve yourself and then gorge
yourself as a you know or yes you don't
uh starve yourself as a punishment for
courtship so just go back to the the
baseline try to keep that going
yeah i mean if you fail
in doing the extra thing then you're
going to feel even worse right
so uh yeah
i've also kind of like i'll go ahead
the base is motivation go on i've seen
people deny after they've failed their
resolution that they ever made the
resolution in the first place
oh that's tough to do
but yeah i've seen people pull it off
you know
it's like
what is that like trying to protect your
like ego or something to like uh oh well
yeah i suppose
i i succeeded everything that i set my
mind to yeah so if i didn't do that then
i did not
actually set my mind to that
now if you haven't broken your
resolutions
i'm actually going to say and i think
dan will go along with me
you have our permission to break as many
of them as you want to you can you can
revise your your resolutions you're not
stuck with them just because you happen
to send something on january 1st or you
know december 31st
we're the ones who are in charge of
whatever resolutions we make they don't
they don't run the show for us and so if
they're not helping you out
it's so you know it's okay to change
them it's okay to revise them it's okay
to
you know
carve them down or replace them with
additional ones or new ones or maybe you
know if things are really bad you could
say i'm not doing any resolutions this
year you know
yeah
um it's kind of like thinking of these
kind of levels of abstraction okay and
so what are the things that you're
uh say i want to
run a half marathon okay what what is
that a a specific example of well that's
you know getting more fit okay um
and so you're getting more extract and
more yeah yeah we're going going up and
so
um
i i might be able to
swap out
like i did in my running example um
because i was no longer able to
physically run yeah but i was still
continued uh biking um at a very high uh
level i guess yeah um
and so i'm still like hitting this like
this kind of this meta idea of what the
resolution was trying to do
um
but just in a different specific uh
example of it yeah you're asking
yourself the question
what was the point what was the goal
what was the the end that i was after
and then you're saying another thing
could satisfy that same goal
but also as you're saying it might be
that the end was wrong you realized that
that end was not the thing that you were
wanting
really in the first place um and you
should
like as you said it's up to you it's
your re-evaluation
um but
uh i would say don't be too wishy-washy
about that uh you don't deal
if you're gonna set out a resolution at
least try it for a month um
see what happens yeah experiment see
what you know like that's definitely
enough time to try to like fill out how
this thing is going if it's going really
really bad yeah you can change it but uh
you know don't don't
wimp out the first day i guess you could
say that
you know failing could be positive in
that you you realize that um
you know this
i shouldn't make these sort of
resolutions or this is a little bit too
much for me or you know
you you could go better at it the next
time around but i want to come back to
this notion of goals because
there's um
you know you can make a resolution but
that's something different than a goal
right
right why is a goal better than
making a resolution
um
you know i'm gonna let you do this
because i don't know if i totally agree
with you oh okay
i so it's connected to what you were
bringing up like figuring out what
you're really looking at i think that
resolutions in a lot of cases
are
at best means to an end and the goal is
what we really want like in your case
you know uh
to not just have better health but to
establish a regular exercise pattern and
enjoy being outside right those are all
those are those could all be goals
things that you value
and when you make something a goal
see with a resolution
you you either stick to it or you break
it and if it's something like i'm going
to read
10 pages from this text every day you
know
i've got seneca's on benefits here now
you could you could read you know 10
pages from that every day you'd read
through the book a number of times over
the years
over the year
but what happens if you miss a day you
you broke into your resolution you feel
like crap you know resolutions like the
one that you made about the doing a half
marathon that's a little bit different
because you're saying i'm going to do
this thing at the end of this so that's
a little bit further down the path
towards almost more like a secondary
goal right
but if i say something like i you know
i'm going to lose um a certain amount of
weight or i am going to you know master
mandarin this year
something like that um i should ask
myself why do i want to learn mandarin
you know is it so that i can read
classical chinese philosophy well
mandarin is actually not gonna it'll
help a little bit with that but that's
not the same thing as classical chinese
so maybe that
resolution isn't achieving that that
goal or it's only a sufficient but not
it's only a necessary but not sufficient
condition for achieving that goal
and
i think that if you if you reframe
things as goals
you're probably for most people better
off
than than working with a resolution now
you see it differently so tell me where
you think that this is
so
i guess this is from at least a number
of you know
sociological studies about uh how we
actually get to these goals okay and
it's great to have kind of these big
goals as kind of an idea of
like
okay say i want to lose you know 20 50
pounds okay
um
it's
that's a really big thing that's really
really far off and it's not easily
actionable on a day-to-day basis
and so this is kind of like your um you
now need to make a
plan in how to actually implement that
yeah and now
the thing that is
better for you especially in the long
run and it helps you maintain
these good
habits um even after you hit these goals
is to set up okay well um
i want to instead of lose 50 pounds that
i'm going to go to the gym
uh
three to five times a week yeah um and
and and
build in that
it's part of your everyday life and
eventually you're going to hit these
goals regardless but now your your goal
hasn't actually gone away you still have
that
uh the goal of actually maintaining that
you know three to five times away and so
these routines um not goals to achieve
long-term success uh result in in
basically long-term behavior change and
habits you've basically described but
not three to five times just at best
three times a week what i did
eight circuits
and losing weight in in this case and i
think you're right so i think maybe
we've got to sum it up real quick
because we're almost at the the end uh
we've got like big long term goals we've
got resolutions that we can make if we
want to and then we've got all these
what would you want to call them
implementation
steps that are that are needed along the
way
yeah these actionable steps okay yeah
and i would say like at least my opinion
uh and from these studies is the
uh the the actual steps that are easy to
do and then make them as easy as
possible so for example on you don't
even need to go and work out of the ship
just make sure that you go to the gym
and make that into a yeah you just hang
around drive to the gym walk in okay
do one jumping jack get out and that's
that's the very minimum that you need
but just make it so you're always doing
that
okay
well you want to lead us out on some
final thoughts then yes with the words
of melody beating the new year stands
before us like a chapter and a book
waiting to be written we can help write
that story by setting goals
[Music]
you